um that drifting video you did was
freaking cool
yeah great thank you very much i watched
that drifting video i was like um i want
to go drift
i mean yeah it's really fun it's
expensive it's really expensive
very expensive like beyond beyond
shinkansen it's expensive like the
drifting itself
yeah is it really yeah yeah i mean alexi
who uh we had on his guess he's a
professional drifter
but like yeah he said like it's one of
the most expensive hobbies out there
i mean you're basically tearing apart a
car yeah yeah yeah yeah
but like we were able to like rent cars
but most of the time
if you want to drift you have to buy a
car like they do because they expect you
if because they expect that car to be
just totaled by the end of yeah yeah
yeah
so you buy a car and it just sits in
that parking lot and you can use it
whenever you want and then you got to
replace the tires
yeah of course and i imagine there's
safety standards that have to be
maintained like a beast here
oh surprisingly not seatbelt regulations
safety is like it's up to you you know
yeah
i don't know if that i could be
completely wrong yeah i mean i've kind
of got that vibe i mean i got the vibe
when you didn't even need a driving
license to yeah yeah
on the driver that's private property so
you can yeah it's like driving in
someone's back
yard right just never license to drive
and jerry doesn't a license to try to
have a license to drive you've got
noises
for real i do right so
they turned we we booked this thing and
i remember there was a big concern we're
like wait
we should at least you don't have
licenses what we can do yeah and then
because we thought we needed like a
manual license and gun and i don't we
only have an automatic license oh god
can drive manual right
yeah i can uh oh okay well i just
haven't done any i don't have a manual
license
like well i'm gonna be screwed and the
guy was like no you don't need it just
jump in
you're fine yeah just learn you're fine
i have to learn
it was for a movie i shot in the
philippines right and um
the tangent here comes the tangent for
i briefly lived in the philippines okay
i worked for a movie studio right
i was a producer and an actor and so i
was acting in a particular film
what haven't you done i literally asked
you like half an hour ago is there any
other like job that you haven't
mentioned yet
when did you go undercover in a gang and
that's the drug raid i'm curious can you
tell me about it
that's why i want this fight to bust the
anime man anime trade
um so the way i look manuals i had to
learn it for this movie
and i'm not a stunt driver i'd never
done stunts in cars
ever okay and they're like yeah yeah so
that's the car i would get this guy who
will teach you how to drive a manual
i've never driven manual
keep in mind it's also on the wrong side
of the road from australia right
on the other side of the car side there
and i spend a few days clickety clacking
buddy hopping away
learn how to do it and then in the movie
the scene that i have to shoot with me
in the car is like
dirt track in this dodgy like
countryside philippines
it's like through the middle of like a
rice paddy so it's like there's the road
and then like a drop on either side
right right
and i have to like come around this
corner
speed it up get up to like 60 or
something going directly at
the camera crew right and then they're
going to pull back on the dolly at the
last second i have to go
and like whiz around them jesus christ
and i'm like you want
a non-stunt driver to do that you really
want a non-stop
did you have to sign any health and
safety stuff or
philippines
nothing happens in japan and you think
the philippines is going to help the
safety disclaimer
brothers sorry so we going for it i'm
sitting there before the first take and
i'm like
well rip camera man
slaughter how how long is that having an
adventure if nothing else yeah right
so but what would happen is this camera
crew as they pulled out on their dolly
one of the guys would jump out onto the
road to pull the freaking camera
didn't tell me he would do that right
right so okay your directions there you
speed up get to 60 that are the last
second just whizz around him
right so no rehearsals
[Music]
60 at this guy okay getting there
freaking out a little bit
do my zing to get around him and then a
man jumps in front of the pound
jesus christ did you hit him uh
did you kill him i think fine
finally i didn't but i then another
taker oh homeless man jumped onto the
road
out of the rice paddy onto the road oh
what the [ __ ]
oh my god oh my god
you have lived like the experience of
like 10 different lives yeah
at least it's [ __ ] crazy oh it's
ridiculous oh my god
i just want to sit in front of a fire
with a cup of tea yeah i do too
after the very interest yeah after the
interesting talks you've told us